So I thought tonight we'd like do a little bit of, um, I guess what they would say is
like character development, right?
Like if we were writing a story, then this episode would be about character development,
like talking a little bit about, you know, some of the things that interest us and some
of the things that have happened recently and, you know, maybe touch on a little astrology
and what's going on in the world, astrologically speaking, but just a little bit more personal.
You know, we've had the opportunity to interview Morgan.
We've talked about a couple of other subjects, but you know, uh, what we didn't have the opportunity
to do yet is to talk about your vacation because you recently took some, some awesome vacation
time and you went to a place that I think a lot of people who are interested in esoteric
or metaphysical studies are familiar with or think about.
And I think just a lot of people like to go on vacation.
Yeah, that sounds good.
I'd be happy to talk about it.
Um, so were you thinking I would just like talk about like where I went and what I did
or, well, yeah, I mean, I figured we'll start off like you just, you know, introduce like
what you did, where you went, and then we'll talk about like specific, specifically the esoteric
connection.
And, you know, you would, um, you would send me some information about what, um, what native
people there say about the area.
Like we talked about the trees and Rick and Morty.
I thought we'd just go over that stuff because it's interesting.
Sure.
Sounds good.
So, Hey, I'm Matt.
Um, welcome to the show.
Yeah.
So, uh, recently I took a trip with my wife, um, to down to Mexico.
We stayed, um, on like a resort down there.
We actually used AI to find the place, which is like a whole new set of skills, like figuring
out how to, cause I guess with the AI, maybe it's a little bit easier to find places that
are less, you know, they, maybe they spend a little bit less money on advertising towards
U S tourists.
Like most of the people that we were around were, you know, from Mexico.
They seem to be like Mexican people that were just going on vacation.
So that was cool.
Um, we went to a place near, uh, Playa del Carmen, I guess is the city.
It's like between Cancun, which I feel like a lot of people are familiar with Cancun and,
uh, and Tulum.
It's kind of like, like a midway point between those two cities.
Is that on the East or West coast?
It's on the East coast.
Cancun is like the Northeast, like tip.
I think, um, it's like the Caribbean, you know, if the North is the, the Gulf and, and
the East is the Caribbean sea, we were, we were on the East coast.
Um, and so as you go down like the East coast, you know, you'll start in Cancun in the North
and, and, and as you go South, you'll hit Playa del Carmen, which is around approximately
where we were.
And, um, and then down after that, you'd get to places like Tulum and then you keep going
too, too much further.
You're, you're kind of out of like the Yucatan area.
Um, so that's where we were.
And, uh, that was really cool.
I'd never been to Mexico before.
I've, I've been to a few different countries, but, but never Mexico.
Um, so that was a really cool experience.
And I've also never been to a resort before.
Um, most of my traveling has been like, I go to a city and I stay in like an Airbnb and
I, and I'm traveling around the city and I'm, it's, it's like, you know, somebody referred
to it as, um, you know, you're on, you're on vacation rather than traveling.
And so I, I, I would, I would agree with that.
I would say most of it was kind of like, we're on the beach and, um, it's like all inclusive.
So you go to like the, you know, the meals, uh, the food was like, food was fine.
Um, uh, but it was mostly just like a, a great place to relax.
It was very hot.
Um, but it's not really such a big deal when you're at the beach.
So that was pretty cool.
Um, and then we were there for a good while, um, like about two weeks, uh, give or take.
And, uh, during our stay, we had a few of these excursions.
So it's like really, it's really common that the, that the resort will offer, you know, they'll
partner with like local tourist companies and they'll, you know, pick you up and bring you
to some of the destinations so that you don't need to worry about like renting a car and, and, and whatnot.
And, um, there's definitely pros and cons to it.
I've, I've done, I've done a few of them.
Uh, well, I did three of them in Mexico and then we did, uh, one in, um, Italy.
Um, my wife and I, when we went there a couple of years ago and it's, it's nice because you can go
and you don't really need to worry about anything and they'll kind of take you to a few different
spots and, and they take you to things that you, you wouldn't necessarily know to go to.
But, um, the, the, the con of course, is that you are with lots of other people and there's
kind of this like hurting, um, component to it where you're not really able to stay where
you want to go and see what you want to see.
Cause you're always kind of in a rush to go off to the next thing.
Um, you know, cause it's, they're trying to make sure everybody is there that they get
on the bus and then they go home.
So anyways, we did three of these excursions and, um, uh, cause in the area it's, it's, uh,
there's quite a few of these like Mayan ruins or, uh, I guess it's Maya ruins.
I don't know.
I was corrected at one point.
I was told by, by someone, uh, who was native to that region that Mayan is, is only correct
when it's in reference to the language and everything else is Maya.
And so, yeah, I mean, I don't know either.
I, that was just what, uh, wait, no, one of my tour guides.
I always tell people I only speak American and just barely, right?
Like I wouldn't even say I speak English.
I would say I barely speak American.
I can't, I try to be as respectful as possible with more names and, you know, and I run into
them a lot, but it's, I'm sure it's a horror show for people listening to me, try to pronounce
words in their language.
So I'm sure you're better than I am Maya.
I'll remember that next time.
Yeah, well, the reason it came up is because, uh, he was talking about some, um, he was referencing
something like the history channel documentary about, about, about Maya people.
And, um, he just noted it like within the first like five minutes, you know, presumably this
guy's an expert and, and, um, you know, within like five minutes he had noticed like three
mistakes in, in, in, in sort of the documentary and that, that that's the only reason why it
came up.
But in any case, so I went to, we went to three of these, um, ruins and, uh, there are some
like very interesting ruins there.
Um, the one that maybe people would be the most familiar with is, um, Chichen Itza, which
is one of the seven new wonders of the world.
So there's like, I don't know, there was the ancient wonders of the world.
And then at some point they, they kind of created a set of seven new ones.
I mean, I've been calling it Chichen Itza since I was a kid.
So now I just learned something else.
Chichen Itza.
Yeah.
That was another one.
Like, you know, when they're down there, they like, they help you pronounce it, but it's
like, it's, uh, Chichen.
Yeah, it's like, there's like an extra syllable there, Chichen Itza.
Um, I forget what it's, uh, stands for.
Um, that doesn't matter.
I'd probably mess it up anyway.
So, um, we went there, that's the first one.
And, um, you know, it was, it was very cool.
I mean, it's a very impressive structure, uh, getting there.
It's probably like a few hours from the resort.
Maybe like an hour and a half.
But, but the problem is of course that you just have to like coordinate and they're picking
everybody up.
So it takes forever.
And when you get there, it's definitely the most.
Like tour, there are the most tourists in, in that area.
Um, like you go there and it's like, wow, you know, you're walking down the path after
you've shown your tickets and you're walking down this path and it's just, the path is
lined with 2000 vendors who, who are all trying to sell you like the same $5 knickknacks.
Um, but so it, for me, it took a little bit away from it.
Um, but, but once you get to the pyramid, um, there's still some people like on the perimeter.
Right.
But, but when you get there, it's very impressive.
Um, it's, it's big, it's not as big as the, the, the like Egyptian ones from what I understand,
but it is, it's, it's, it's big to me.
And, uh, something that was really cool about it was if you go to the north facing side of
the, of the pyramid and you clap in a certain location, the sound reflects off of the surrounding
buildings and it makes a sound that is very, very similar to the, the, the Ketzel, the, the
bird that like is Quetzalcoatl, right?
The, this like dragon serpent bird.
Yeah.
That's cool.
Which, which is very impressive.
Um, so that was cool.
And, and despite the fact that the buildings are, you know, a lot of them are like pretty
torn down, um, so that one was cool.
That was the first one we went to.
They don't let you climb up on that one anymore.
Uh, back in the eighties, they, they used to let you do that, but, but they stopped letting
you climb on that one.
Um, and then kind of a recurring theme of these excursions was we went to, um, these like
cenotes afterwards and cenote, uh, I guess like the translation is sinkhole, but the, but
the way I would describe it is like, it's this underground body of water that is very filtered.
It's very like pure water because the water gets there by, um, filtering down through many
feet of limestone.
And so, you know, as, as it's, uh, trickling down, it's, it's, it's getting really, really
cleaned out by, by interaction with the limestone.
Um, so it's very clear water.
Um, and that was cool.
They let you swim in there.
I guess there's some, uh, contention about, you know, whether they should be letting you
swim in there or not, just because, um, it was like many of these cenotes were like a
spiritual place for, for some of the ancient peoples, especially.
There's treasures under there.
Did they tell you about that?
Oh yeah.
And the bones too.
Yeah.
I mean, the bones, right.
But the thing is, it's not your treasure.
It's, it's, uh, it's the God or whoever they, you know, whoever they left that to, that
doesn't stop people from going in there and trying to appropriate the God's treasure.
So I think that's part of the contention.
I don't think you get there without a scuba diver, you know, but I think a scuba diver can
get there.
Yeah, they are deep.
I mean, they, uh, they, they are, some of them are as deep as the pyramids are tall.
I mean, they are, they're pretty deep.
Not, not all of them are deep, but there's a lot of, um, there's a lot of ones that are
like a hundred feet down.
I mean, maybe that's too far, but definitely at least 50 feet.
And, um, yeah, they tell you right away, uh, that don't bring anything in there that
you're like loose, that you're, that you are not okay with losing, um, like jewelry and
whatnot, because if it does sink to the bottom, no one's, no one's going down there to get
it.
Um, but I guess it's like a common practice, uh, or it was a common practice to, yeah, throw
like sacrifices in there.
And, and, and, and, you know, sometimes they were literal, uh, and sometimes they were metaphorical,
I think, but, so there's definitely like treasure down there.
And like, I guess they valued silver a lot.
That was like, they, they, gold, not so much is my understanding.
Like their word for gold was kind of like, um, you know, like, uh, it's like a, like a
sun turd, I guess.
I don't know a more graceful way of saying that, but that was basically what they called
it.
And they didn't value it as, as much as, as they valued the silver, I guess.
Um, and so anyways, we went to these cenotes after, um, and then we'd like, they would take
us out to lunch and whatnot.
And that was kind of the excursion.
So we did three of them.
First was, uh, Chichen Itza.
The second was a place called, uh, Coba, which is less well, I would say of the three that
we went to, it was definitely the least touristy.
And it was definitely my, my favorite.
Um, because when you get there, you can't like drive up to it or even close to it.
Like the parking lot is at least three miles away from the pyramid.
So it's very common for people to rent, um, bicycles and, you know, just like a couple
bucks, um, get a bike, uh, and, and, and ride out there.
And, and as you're riding along, you can kind of see other structures, which is cool.
Um, and like there are buildings that they, they say were like observatories, uh, and things
like that.
And, um, yeah, this one is very cool because it's big.
So the one in, uh, Coba was called Nohawk Mool, I think, and I have no idea if I pronounced
that right, but something like that.
And it's, it's the tallest one in that area.
It's not the tallest one overall, but it's, it's the tallest one in that, uh, Yucatan
area.
And, and what's cool about it is it, it is, it's one of the only ones left that they'll
let you climb.
And they had shut it down for a couple of years because people, and so in order to get
up to the top, like, you know, the pyramids, like, uh, like there are steps, right.
But it's not like a step, uh, like you would walk up the stairs, like these, they're pretty
steep steps.
And, um, coming down is, is definitely nerve wracking.
Uh, so people would, would kind of like slide on their butt and, and go down one step at
a time.
But I think that at some point they realized that, that that was kind of a recipe for disaster
and they shut it down for a couple of years and they put in some stairs.
And so now there are like actual stairs to help you navigate up and it's still nerve wracking.
Um, but yeah, it's, it's cool and you can climb up there and, and basically they, what, what
they told us was that the, the height of the pyramid is sort of arbitrary.
Like they didn't build them necessarily to be really tall.
They only built them to be as tall as they needed to get above the tree line, to get above the
canopy.
So in areas where the trees were shorter, there was, there was no real reason to, to make
them big.
And that, in that, uh, um, and another thing that's, it's, that's good to know about that
area, like, uh, geographically is that it's very flat.
So there aren't these, like, if you were going to look at the stars, right.
And to, to, to figure out, you know, make decisions based on that, um, there aren't really any
mountains to go build observatories in that area.
Uh, so basically they made mountains.
They made these, these structures that resemble mountains, uh, that they didn't have in, in
the area and they built them to be as tall as they needed to be to get above the trees
so they could get a good look at the stars, which is pretty cool.
And then a common thing amongst all the pyramids as well, or at least that I know of is that
underneath the pyramids, there are cenotes and, and these ones, they don't, they don't let
you, uh, yeah, they don't let you swim in, swim in there.
There's definitely, the one under Chichen Itza, you definitely need to scuba.
You, like, there's no way to get to it unless you start from, like, one that's pretty far
away and then scuba in, uh, and there's definitely stuff down there.
Um, you need, uh, special permission to, to go there.
So we weren't, we weren't hanging around in there, but, um, so yeah, that was cool.
Uh, and then the last one was called, uh, Tulum, which Tulum would is like, um, so there is a
city, like there's the, the archeological site Tulum, but there's also a city Tulum, like
a new, new Tulum, but I, they don't call it that.
I just call it Tulum, I think.
And, um, that's like, I guess becoming like a popular vacation spot as well.
Kind of like a Cancun vibe, but a little bit less, but the ruins there are cool because
they're on the water.
Um, so there, it was like this, this area was like a, like a port, I guess, you know, like
a place for people to trade, um, where it was on the water so they could bring people
and they could bring their ships in, they could dock their ships.
And there is a wall around the city, um, to make sure that they could kind of protect
that area while they were there, they're doing their trade.
And so there's still some buildings there and they still have these like interesting alignments
on, on certain days, like on the, um, the solstice or the, or the equinox, there is like cool stuff
that, that you can see, um, like for, for example, in the Chichen Itza, there, uh, there's
like a snake that comes down on the equinox, I think.
Yeah.
Like the spring and fall equinox is like the only time of the year where the sunlight from
the steps reflects onto this statue of a snake and you can actually see kind of a serpent
zigzag that, that starts and stops with the, with the head of a snake.
Um, but yeah, in Tulum, it was like, I guess it was kind of cool.
I think it was, for me, it was like the least, um, impressive, but like still pretty cool.
Um, something I think that was notable for Tulum was they had, um, yeah, they were, they had
like, um, like imprints of hands, but the hands had, uh, like more, more, like not, they
weren't like, uh, five finger hands.
They were like six or seven finger hands.
And what the tour guide said was that it was, you know, very common for the kind of royalty
of that, of the nations to, um, kind of like game of Thrones style, um, marry.
And they would have these like genetic, uh, deformities that they viewed as, you know, something
that was very good.
Right.
Um, so in any case, that was cool.
Um, and I guess another thing that's interesting to note about Tulum is that it's newer.
So it's definitely the new, the newest of the three, like there would have been people at
Tulum doing trade when the Spanish, uh, came through.
So I, I, my understanding is that the Spanish would have known about, um, the Tulum as we
see it today.
So those were kind of the three, the three, uh, that I, that I visited and, um, yeah, it
was, it was a cool experience.
I very much enjoyed it.
Uh, I got to practice speaking a bit of Spanish.
I don't speak very well.
Um, I studied it in high school and then I kind of stopped, um, and, and focused more on,
on, like engineering.
So, um, it was cool to be able to use that because there are definitely a lot of people
that spoke English well, but there were quite a few people that did not.
And, um, it was helpful to be able to, to, to just speak in Spanish with them and, and they
were able to easily understand what I was trying to say.
Um, and there was less room for confusion.
So it was cool.
Yeah.
I took Spanish for years at the end of it.
I only knew a couple of curse words.
Um, so again, not really much of a language scholar, but that's why I think, right.
People take those languages to have that opportunity.
So that must've been really, really cool to be able to do that.
Yeah, for sure.
Um, sorry, but my mic was, uh, off.
So you had mentioned, um, I don't know how we got there in, um, a conversation, an online
conversation, text conversation.
Um, but you had mentioned, um, and I see, I hadn't thought about this.
Um, I, I think I was aware of this, I think a couple of things come to mind.
Like one, supposedly it's part of new age esoteric lore that one of the reasons that they don't
let people climb the pyramids anymore is that on certain nights of the year, the star brothers
descend to the pyramids.
Um, I don't know what that looks like because I've never found any specific, um, description
of how that would work.
Like, you know, I don't know if there's a, if they're, when they say that they're saying
there's like a gray alien standing on top of the pyramid.
I don't think that's what they're saying.
I think they're talking about warps.
And so with Mesoamerican ruins, there are often, um, reports of like orb light type, um,
activity, uh, particularly in the Incan area, but also in the Mayan area on the pyramids
at certain, you know, on or during, or, you know, related to certain nights of the year.
Um, and specifically blue lights, you know, this is like, um, this is like some very esoteric
lore anywhere else.
Um, other than when we're talking to people who like might have some connection to the UAP
community or like UAP fan community or whatever it is.
But apparently the blue lights are the ones you don't want to tangle with.
Um, so they, you know, if you, if you see a colored orb, because this didn't really happen
when I was younger, they'd find them in photos, but they didn't really see them very often
outside of areas like Mesoamerica.
Um, but apparently if you should run into like a colored orb, if it's white or green or yellow
or red, not such a big deal.
If it's blue and I don't know what the danger is again, it's, it's, it's, um, probably
conspire attainment or a conspire attainment lore.
Um, but it could be who knows.
Right.
But I guess the blue ones are the ones you avoid.
And those are the ones that are up on the pyramids.
And, um, supposedly that's one of the reasons they don't let people up there anymore.
Again, you know, probably an urban myth.
Um, but something interesting that you would, you'd mentioned, you sent me a communication
saying like, I think that you said they're like trees going above the canopy and with
the roots going down into the, into the say note.
Is that how you said it?
Yes.
Cenote.
Yeah.
And I think that I had heard this before.
Like, I know that there are sacred mountains that are pyramid like, like Mount Kailash in
Tibet or in China, right over the border from Tibet is pyramid like.
And I know that they had talked about that as being like a representation of the world
tree and prior to that, I believe that I had heard that about the great pyramid, but I'm
not positive, but I don't think I internalized it until we had that conversation.
And then I had an epiphany.
I'm like, Oh, that's why they built them.
I mean, people will argue that there are all kinds of like this ceremonial reasons.
There's sacrificial reasons.
There's the wowing the populace.
Right.
And, you know, presenting a grand spectacle for the, you know, to, to, um,
uh, impose the social order, you know, like, you know, we're up here, you're down there.
Look at what we built.
Um, but I think that there's a connection to the, the universal world tree myth.
And I think that I've heard this before, but you, like, I didn't expect you to bring it
up.
Like, I didn't think I wasn't thinking about it.
I'd never thought about it in the context of Mesoamerican pyramids.
And then I got that message from you.
I'm like, Oh, that's what it is.
And I think that what really drove that home was when you told me about how they build them
over the Cenote.
Right.
Which is where like the roots would go down into the earth, into the water of a tree.
And then I was like, Oh, this makes perfect sense.
And built them large enough to be above the, the other, uh, um, trees that the foliage of
the other trees.
Obviously one reason was to, to chart the stars, which is what they did.
Another reason was, you know, for the dramatic effect during sacrifices and, you know, who knows,
maybe the star brothers were, you know, are bopping down there and they need to see where they
need to land.
I don't know.
Um, we don't have star brothers here in Massachusetts, but, um, that I'm aware of.
And if we do have them, then they can visit someone else.
Um, but when I saw that and I was like, Oh my God.
And then you had mentioned something about a Rick and Morty tree.
And so I sent you that information about the, um, so there's this, um, again, I don't know
if it's an, I wouldn't call it an urban myth.
I wouldn't call it a conspiracy theory because it's treated as a conspiracy theory in, you
know, like mainstream Western scientific circles, but it's treated as a fact in Aboriginal Native
American and other Aboriginal circles.
And so I think that it's, um, one, I wouldn't necessarily bet on the scientists, right.
To be honest with you over the, over the native elders.
And two, it's very colonialist to impose that on them to say, no, this isn't what it is.
But we have one in the United States.
We have a remnant, at least one of a world tree.
And that's, it's called, um, devil's tower in South Dakota or North Dakota.
I think it's South Dakota.
Have you ever heard of it?
No, I'm not beyond, uh, what you linked.
Yeah.
So there is this, there's, there's a lot of pareidolia in the world.
And that is when people look at, um, inanimate objects and they see human traits.
So sometimes when it comes to like finding faces carved in rocks, when people say there's a face
carved in the rocks, it's, it's just pareidolia.
It's just a rock that looks vaguely like a face.
Other times they find these, what the remnants of ancient communities on Google or with these
clearly like human faces carved in cliff faces and things like that.
So it's easy to dismiss everything as a form of pareidolia or as some sort of, some sort of
psychological projection.
And with this, this world tree phenomenon, uh, like devil's tower, um, which the native,
uh, people of that area do not care for the term devil's tower at all.
They call it grandmother tree.
So with grandmother tree, um, the petrified plateau has visual, um, indicators that it
was once a large tree.
Now you, people can disbelieve it, but when you look at it, when you look at a picture,
you're like, Oh yeah, I can see the bark clearly like this bark or what would be the petrified
remains of bark at the, at the bottom of the stump.
And then when you go to the very flat, it's always very flat, not flat, like a natural
rock formation, flat, like a tree, somebody cut in half.
So if you've ever seen a tree that just got cut down like a flat ass stump, and when you
look down from above on that flat ass stump, and these things are giant, some of them are
miles wide.
Um, what you see is like very clearly, very similar to tree rings.
So you see many concentric rings in the, what would be the trunk of this tree.
Now they tell you that's a natural phenomenon and you know, nature often rhymes.
Um, so it's not beyond possibility, but the story is that, um, and you probably, I'm sure
you know this, but prior to trees on earth, there were mushrooms.
There were big ass mushrooms, 20 feet, 30 feet high, um, prior to the beginning of trees.
And this was hundreds of millions of years ago.
Right.
And then sometime during that period, uh, trees evolved, but we'll use that.
I mean, who knows, but you know, trees appeared.
And, um, at, at that time for, according to the indigenous people, uh, there, they talk
about periods of like 200 million years now, am I saying that's absolutely true?
No, I'm not.
Is that what some of them say?
Yeah, absolutely.
Um, where these giant trees existed on the earth.
And I think there were anywhere between 13 and 30 something of these rock formations.
I shouldn't remember that.
And I'm just getting it jumbled in my head.
Like, where's the three, you know, is it like 37?
Is it 13?
I know the one in the United States.
I should have the others memorized.
I don't.
Um, it's always been a curiosity to me, but not like a, something I'm super, super into,
but the natives say that, um, while petrified on the outside, grandma, the tree is still alive.
That's what they say, because the roots, they say, stretch out for like 400 miles.
And go deep into the aquifers beneath the earth and tiny mycelium sized roots.
They believe connect to all of the trees within hundreds of miles, providing like life, like
sustenance that, um, that the roots of this stump are so deep that they're pulling up water and
minerals from like way, way deep in the earth and distributing like a tiny bit to each of these
trees, almost like an Aspen where an entire grove of Aspen trees is one tree.
Now they, the native people even believe that the, um, the roots, the tiny mycelia or roots
or mycelia is mushrooms.
I don't know what the technical name is for the tiny, tiny tree roots.
Um, but that they even connect to like blades of grass.
And I, I, you know, I think that might be, um, romanticism, you know, that might be like
a, a part of this spirituality that we wouldn't actually find, but I wouldn't be surprised if
this story was true because it seems to be a universal story.
And when you look into the quote mythology, um, and original beliefs of ancient people, these
giant trees are everywhere.
And it's sort of an odd thing to have a sort of like a universal conception, right?
Like to have this universal concept of a world tree of these giant trees that were had trunks
that were a mile or two wide.
And God only knows the foliage would have gone up, up to 10 miles in the air.
And I imagine if it went up 10 miles in the air, then it was probably what, I mean, 40 or
50 miles wide.
Right.
But the idea even shows up now in our fiction, like avatar where they had like giant trees.
So it's like a, it's a very powerful archetype that, that seems really universal.
And when you were talking about the cenotes under the pyramids, and I think you mentioned,
and I'm not certain the exact words that you use, but the, the, you drew a comparison.
And that's when I had the epiphany that these, that the pyramids, I believe, and I'm sure other
people have said this, I'm not, you know, I'm not claiming this is like an original thought.
It's original to me, but, um, are, you know, um, artificial, um, artificial monuments to
the, the concept of world treats, which were sort of the center of civilizations and sort
of the center of the world at that time, um, in the, in the mythical past.
And we're supposedly cut down by gods or, um, something, some sort of God-like life form,
you know, the ancient aliens or whatever your cosmology is.
Uh, apparently they got rid of them.
And then, so you had mentioned, um, like you, you tied it together in the message you sent
me by talking about this Rick and Morty episode.
Now I don't have access to brand new Rick and Morty episodes.
I'm not, um, I have cable, which used to be like the line, like if you had cable, you
were doing okay, but I don't have, I can't do all the special services.
Right.
Cause like each one is like 30 bucks, 30 bucks for this, 30 bucks for that.
And it's just not, it's just not worth it.
And it's not within my, my, um, it's not, you know, my finances don't allow me to do stuff
like that, even if I wanted to, which I really don't.
Um, but I love Rick and Morty.
Um, so I was, when you described it to me, I was like, oh, wow, that like, you're right.
That really ties into like the whole intuitive underground slash, um, simulation concept.
Yeah, totally.
I, so just to, um, yeah, it was, it was interesting to me too, because so, so I, I made that post.
Um, you know, most of the time when I post on social media, it's just like, you know, throw
it up pictures.
Right.
But for whatever reason, I felt called to, to kind of make this post that was a bit more
of like, um, yeah, I don't know, like a little, a little more creative, I guess.
And, um, most, most of the post was me, I'm like going to this, like Koba trip.
Right.
And what was very interesting to me about that trip was, yeah.
So first it was, I, we went to, um, Koba and, and the tour guide there, he used the term,
um, he said, these, these pyramids are sacred man-made mountains that man made.
To view the stars.
They were the connection to the heavens, to the world above.
And, uh, the cenotes were their connection to, to the underworld, you know, whatever association
you make with that.
And so, um, yeah, it was interesting to me because it, uh, when it became clear that the,
the pyramids, they're built just, just high enough to, to reach above the canopy.
Right.
And in the cenotes, there, the roots of some of these trees, you, you can see them that
they break through over 50 feet, sometimes 60 feet of, of, of limestone.
The, the trees, you know, there are little cracks where the water goes, right?
So the roots follow the water and they find their way through, through 50 or 60 feet of rock.
And they, and they clump together and they finally, they reach the, the waters in, in, of the
cenote and the sinkhole.
And once one has gone and, and reached, you know, more follow, right?
Cause the trees grow down as much as they grow up, right?
Like we think of trees as, as growing upwards, uh, but they also grow downwards with their
roots, right?
So they grow in both directions and, um, and the trees are growing.
And they're sending their roots through the, through the rock to get to the water.
And sometimes if, if, if, if the gaps allow, let's say, uh, the trees can push so many of
these little roots that they cluster together and they twist in a way that they, they look
like huge, um, lengths of rope, right?
Like that is the best way I could describe it.
It, it, it literally looks like, um, you know, usually rope, it's like something you can
grab, but these, these ones, you'd have to hug them, right?
Like they're big and they're, they're big and they're thick and they, and they're down 50
feet to get to the, to the limestone.
And when I saw that and I, and I, by something about my brain made the connection that what was,
what was together with the, because these, of course, the, the pyramids are, are on top
of the cenotes, right?
Um, but what connected the cenote through to the pyramid was, was also this tree.
And, um, yeah, it was just something, uh, like the pyramids connect us to the world above.
Um, the, the cenotes connect us to the world below and, and we have a connection here on
this plane to both.
We have access to both worlds.
Um, and the, and the tree is there through, through all.
So I just thought that that was really cool.
And then, so I, I made that post, like, I don't know, like a month, a month ago, a month
and a half ago, something like that.
And then the other day I'm watching Rick and Morty with my brother-in-law, uh, not you,
my, my brother-in-law, my wife's brother, and, and I'm watching it with him.
And, um, we're, you know, most of the time we watch Rick and Morty, I mean, they can be
kind of hit or miss, right?
Like some of them, some of them are good, but, but, but a lot of them are pretty, it
can be pretty mid, right?
Like they're fine.
But this one, we were both like, wow, this is, this is a good episode.
And it's, if you follow it's season nine, episode seven, something like, uh, something to do
with a rainforest is the title.
I, I don't quite remember, but the premise of the story is that Rick and Morty are together
and they're, um, they're going out and collecting the sap for like, whatever the sap is kind
of irrelevant, but it's just the, the lead to get them into, to talk into this tree.
So they're, they're collecting the sap from the tree, um, because it has some kind of
value.
And, and as they're collecting it, they realize that this tree is, is sentient and it can talk
to them.
And the tree is of course, you know, very upset that they are collecting this sap and, uh,
the tree is like, I'll show you, you know, and it, and it sucks them up and it, and it
takes their, you know, what I would, I would refer to it as like a soul, right.
But whatever is the essence of their identity, it, it takes that away from their physical body
and it could, and it brings them down to, to the root system and inside, like if you were
to like go inside the tree, if it were hollow, let's say, and, and follow it down.
It brings them down and below the, the, the earth there of whatever this planet is, there
is, um, like a whole other, um, a whole other world, right.
Kind of like, if you've seen, like, I think, I feel like there's been some, uh, movies where
maybe it's like Jurassic park, some of the more recent Jurassic park movies where there's
like dinosaurs underneath the earth or something like that.
It was that kind of world and they basically entered, um, like a simulation where they would
start, you know, it was like a video game where they would start, each of them would start as
a, an amoeba that was kind of like level one, right.
And they're there and they're amoebas and they're like, ah, geez, what am I going to do?
And, um, the first thing that happens is some bigger amoeba comes and, and kills them and,
and then they respawn.
So like, then they realize that like, okay, I'm amoeba, I die, I respawn and over and over and
over again.
And then eventually they kind of work their way up, right.
They, they figure out how to evolve consciously.
And so after a few times they're, they're able to kind of figure out how to be fish and
they're eventually, they're able to figure out how to get onto the earth and, um, you know,
Rick kind of goes in the direction of, I need to get to the tree.
I need to figure out how to beat the tree.
I need to figure out how to tear this thing down, get out.
You know, everybody else is, is just in my way.
I'm going to kill whoever I need to kill to get there.
And Morty goes along with them for a little while.
Um, but then eventually Morty's like, ah, I don't like this violence thing.
I'm not really into it.
I'd rather be, you know, not doing that.
And he meets some other people who are in the simulation and they tell him, oh, like,
well, the tree, the tree person, he's put you here for a reason.
He doesn't like the, the space fairers, the people who come to his planet.
He doesn't like them because they're always coming to try to conquer other planets.
And, uh, eventually, you know, he's going to teach it that we're all here to put here for
a reason.
And we're going to learn something about, you know, why it is that we've been imprisoned here.
And eventually after enough cycles, um, you know, the tree is going to, is going to tell
us why we're here and we're going to be able to figure out, but until then, you know, the
solution is we have to be peaceful.
We can't kill people.
We have to just, um, you know, continue existing.
And so he kind of goes on, on this path forward and, you know, he goes and he ends up evolving
into like more peaceful creatures.
Whereas Rick is kind of like turning into like a, like a, like a chimp and then going
out and like organizing the chimps to try to figure out how to, you know, well, if I'm
going to, I'm just going to like throw these chimps at the tree and see how it defends and
learn how to try to get up there.
And Morty, he becomes like a turtle and he's, you know, being peaceful.
And eventually Morty's like, ah, this isn't working.
Uh, I'm not so sure about this.
I'm going to go in another direction.
And he ends up like starting over, becoming an amoeba and figuring out a way to evolve into
a plant.
So he becomes, you know, the like cyanobacteria of the water.
And then he becomes like moss and he gets up on the, on the, on the, uh, ground and he
becomes, he eventually becomes a tree himself that can grow up alongside a vine.
That's like growing up alongside the tree.
And eventually he can, uh, and the tree doesn't notice.
Right.
So eventually like this vine gets all the way up to the top and he kind of sprouts out and
he, and he starts talking to the tree and he's like, Hey, I figured it out.
You know, uh, I understand why we're here.
We're not supposed to be, um, like hurting people.
And, you know, I, I, you know, I, I just wanted to let you know that like, I figured it out and
like, we have to be peaceful and it's important.
And, and, and I'm, and thank you for teaching me this lesson.
And the tree is just like, Oh, you're not supposed to be here.
Uh, you know, this is kind of like my thing, right?
You're, you're, you're, you know, I'm, I'm, I'm the only tree that's, that's supposed to
be here.
And he, and he sends them back down.
And, and that's when they figure out that, that the whole time the tree has put them
there, not to teach them a lesson, but the tree is just like feeding off of the energy
of them killing each other.
It's the, it's the, every time that they're, they die and that they're reborn, it feeds the,
the, it nourishes the tree in some way.
And that's when they figure out, Oh, okay.
Like the only way to break out is to stop killing each other.
Like you guys have to stop killing each other.
Like we, we can't, no one can die.
And if no one dies, then, Oh great.
Uh, you know, the tree is going to like not be able to eat and he's going to get weak.
And eventually, you know, they, they do the, the, the, the, the tree gets weak and they,
and they figure out a way to kill it and, and they get out.
But, but it just like struck me as like, Oh man, like this feels very close to the canon
material that you guys have been talking about.
A hundred percent.
So they, they inserted the story of the archons into the metaphor of the tree.
So they took the, the, the archonic story of the creation of the, the false reality and
farming us for energy and, and other purposes.
Um, and they inserted into the, like the native, um, aboriginal spirituality around the world
tree and around the sacredness of all life.
Because one of the things that you, one of the ideological conflicts that you run into
when you start pursuing knowledge of the, that we'll call it the simulation, the matrix,
the reality overlay, whatever you want to call it, the dream, right?
The world dream is you run into, um, a strong barrier with love and light people who are
like heavily immersed in, um, uh, the unity of all living things, spirituality, the cycle
of life.
And, uh, it's, it's a barrier for them that they, they have difficulty crossing.
Because for them, there's, um, a sacredness to the process, right?
Or, um, it's like a psychological coping mechanism for them as, as individuals, right?
Instead of, instead of thinking about death, they think about themselves as being part of
this like holistic, um, system.
It gives, it gives their, their life meaning when they otherwise as individuals might not
have that meaning or, or sense of purpose.
Um, people who are, you know, and that's not the Aboriginal people themselves.
That's their ancient, um, that's their ancient lore, right?
That's their culture.
Um, but people who are drawn to that, um, because generally speaking, when we have these discussions,
we're not talking to Aboriginal peoples.
We're not talking to first nations peoples.
We're talking to, you know, other white guys or, you know, other, um, like, um, modern Americans
who have embraced, um, certain ideals, certain, um, belief systems as a, as a, some kind of compensation
or some kind of psychological, um, self-soothing or, or whatever.
We're just, we're just part of their search for meaning, right?
Like, it's not wrong.
Um, but it just, they, they don't, they don't really fit.
They don't, they don't jive with the, um, with the, uh, agnostic beliefs with beliefs
about the, uh, the world being a simulation with the intuitive underground material.
So that's really clever how they did that.
I, I like that juxtaposition because, you know, their writers are very intelligent people.
And so it's not like they come up with these stories by accident.
Like they, they know, um, they know what they're doing.
And I also like the solution at the end is one of the things that we often run into when
we start having these conversations about the simulation is the injustice of the whole
thing.
If you follow the IU canon material, or if you follow ancient sources talking about reality
and how we got there, the story seems very unjust, right?
And so then you have religious systems and spiritual, uh, disciplines that grow up around
it that if you're not familiar with how the system works, they seem to be moralizing.
So you, you, you come across this information that says basically like, Hey, you're a prisoner
in this life.
And, you know, depending on who you ask, like, you know, if you read like the Apophicon of
John or ancient Gnostic texts, or if you listen to, uh, or read the IU canon material or other
sources, right?
Like you were a prisoner before you got here, like you were a prisoner.
And then they did this, you know, they put you in this, um, uh, reality overlay.
Right.
So, um, the injustice there is like, well, I'm, I've been wronged and believe me, there
are, this idea is not, um, this is not a new idea or a new discussion in esotericism.
This is like a fundamental discussion of the deep esotericism where you get like a lot of
these, ostensibly these forms of spirituality, these cults, these occult societies that have
this sort of like the secret of life is to do what you want.
Like the secret of life is that we were, we were put here.
We didn't have a say.
And what really pleases the people who put us here is when we do bad things.
And so the secret is that we tell everyone we're doing good things, but in secret, we're doing bad
things.
Now, this is something that's come up this year, right?
Because I'm not going to go like too deeply into it, but this ties into, you know, networks
like the Epstein network.
And there are others, right.
Who have this type of belief at its core, like fully developed.
So, and this is going back hundreds, if not thousands of years, right?
So the idea is like, Hey, we're in a prison, so let's just be prisoners, right?
Let's, and let's suck up to the guards.
Right.
And if they, if they get fed by us doing negative things, let's do negative things because then
we might get a little, um, interest, a little big from, uh, from doing it.
Right.
That might give us a little bit of a reward.
That is the basis of quite a few of these like deep esoteric and occult societies that
what they believe.
So when you confront them and you say, look, the secret here is right.
Not to engage in moralizing.
Like we were here.
We may not have wanted to be here.
This may not be a good place.
This may be a place of suffering.
This may be something that's imposed on us, but whether it's a just or unjust situation
is, is, is not helpful to resolving the situation.
Right.
Because what keeps the situation, um, going, what, what keeps the injustice and suffering of
this world, um, happening and going is, is, is that people cooperate with it, right?
Like, you know, animals want to survive.
So they, they kill each other and people want to survive.
So we do things and people not only want to survive, but we want to suffer as little as
possible, which is something animals want to, but they don't have the same understanding
of it.
So we're better.
Like natural selection is externalizing one suffering, right?
Like every time a little bird evolves a little bit longer beak to get some of the food that
the other birds then can't get, like those other birds starve and die.
And that little bird, he does okay, but eventually he gets old and he dies too, right?
So he is temporarily delaying his own suffering at the expense of multiplying the suffering of
everyone else.
That's, that's the basis of natural selection.
So when you apply that to our, our situation, human beings are so good at externalizing our
suffering, right?
Like we used to starve all animals spend or in most areas of the world, spend a certain
period of each year starving.
That's why we get fat preparing for the winter and animals do too.
So, you know, human beings first developed animal husbandry and agriculture as a way of avoiding
the suffering that, that comes with seasonal starvation.
But we're so good at externalizing our suffering that now, unless you're very poor, if you live
in the developed world, you can eat as much as you want and you can satisfy pretty much
every desire that you have in the way of eating, right?
You can eat, you can eat meat, you can eat rare meat, like rare kinds of meat as well as
rare meat, right?
They can eat sugar and sweets and, and fruit and vegetables and roots and all kinds of stuff
from other areas of the world that you never would have even known existed.
And you can do that as like a average American on an average salary in the United States.
And you can do that in most other developed areas of the world as well, right?
And there are some places, as we all know, where people indulge in like even more.
They eat all kinds of things.
So, and that's whatever, that's not a judgment, it's just different from our culture, right?
So the thing about that is we have externalized our suffering.
We don't have to worry about starving, most of us, right?
And as a matter of fact, starving, starvation is a weight loss strategy.
That's a strategy to improve one's life at this point.
We've been so successful at externalizing that suffering, but in order to do it, we've created
a vast, globalized, industrialized network of animal torture.
Now, people tune out when I start talking about this because we might all agree on UFOs or
astrology.
We might all be interested in those subjects, but the majority of people are not interested
in hearing someone talk about animal suffering.
And I get it.
So I'm not going to go and elaborate on it.
I'm not, this is an APTA commercial, right?
But what I'm saying is like, that is the ultimate metaphor for exactly why the situation
continues or the suffering continues.
Because as long as we cooperate with creating more suffering for each other, the humans and
other, you know, life forms in order to temporarily reduce our own suffering, right?
Like this, this cycle will never stop.
It will always keep going.
And so regardless of moralizing, right?
Like we've set aside the moralizing and say, okay, it's, you know, where it may be just
that we're here.
It may be unjust that we're here.
And, you know, and if you don't deserve to be here, to be here, like maybe you can find
it just to do the things that you want to improve your experience from a subjective point of
view to have greater pleasure, to have greater wealth, to have whatever it is that you want.
Right.
But as long as we all do that, we're all going to be stuck here.
So this is like a prisoner's dilemma situation, right?
And as long as someone is willing to sell everyone out, I mean, you know, metaphorically, then
we all eventually face the suffering of old age and death and possibly doing this repeatedly
and possibly, you know, possibly having like worse ramifications in the future.
So that's, I think that's very interesting that they tied that in there because their solution
to the problem was my solution to the problem.
And it's the solution that is the, the basis of spiritual movements, wherever they develop
in history.
So whether you believe in, whether you're an early Christian believer, or you believe in
the societies that exist in that area prior to Christianity, like the Therapeutae or the
Essenes, whether you are a Zoroastrian, whether you are a Buddhist, I, there are holes in my
understanding of Islam, and that's always a touchy subject, but I can say that Sufism also
contains some of these ideas, if not all of them.
I don't know.
But I do know they contain a lot of them.
So, you know, regardless of what your Hinduism, right, all those spiritual doctrines began
with the recognition that as long as we continue to externalize our suffering onto others in
order to improve our own lives, the, we're, we're creating the juice, the energy that keeps
the system going.
So I thought that was when you, when you told me that, I was like, yeah, you're right.
That is a, that is a perfect metaphor analogy.
That's a perfect way of understanding what they're saying.
And that's definitely what they intended.
And it's also really important for what we talk about, because one of the things we, we
mentioned is the ideas related to the simulation, both its existence, how it exists and what
it's like to exist inside of it are an emerging archetype right now.
The same way, like zombies were an emerging archetype for years prior to the pandemic.
And usually the, the, well, that we'll talk about that in another episode, but in the same
way, or the dance macabre emerged prior to, and simulate simultaneously with the black death.
This, this, this archetype is, is emerging in popular fiction, you know, whether you're talking
about like something that might be for kids or for, for people who have like a certain
interest, like comic books to science fiction and now television and first science fiction
television, and now mainstream television and music and people making videos on the internet
and now people's conversations.
And now there's a, there's a phenomenon of tech bros who embrace the belief in, in simulation
ism, appropriate it and claim they created it and write books about it and grift off of
it and make a living doing it.
Like this is becoming a real thing that's bubbling up everywhere.
And so like talking about the fact that it showed up in Rick and Morty is, is important.
It had, it showed up a prior to that in Rick and Morty.
right but like the more novel the medium the less diluted the information because there are less
filters to try to modify it to make it acceptable so it's it's very important to notice and talk
about like how often this is coming up this this archetype is emerging in speculative fiction so
i'm really glad that you brought it up um i know that i'm on a i'm on a um i'm on a i'm i'm still
going here right um the word is this is great thank you yeah thank you good content yeah so i i wanted
to point out one thing i i don't know i don't know as much about trees as i should i know it sounds
weird there have been a number i'm i'm not by nature i the thing is the more i talk about myself
the more like a an ultra hippie i sound and i know that it's not really my nature i'm kind of like um
a rough working class guy from boston who also just has this um these interests right and and
like a certain kind of intelligence so i'm kind of um i'm i'm sort of like and not by because i
you know i i i was alive long before goodwill hunting was a movie right but if you're going
to describe me i would be more closer to like the guy from goodwill hunting than i would be to like a
hippie except i can't you know deny that i do have like some pretty strong sort of new agey kind
of buddhisty like leanings right so i don't like not only do i not like harming animals but i don't
like cutting down trees big trees old trees i don't really like it and when i was younger you know the
whole idea was it's just dead wood it's just you know there's living wood and there's dead wood you just
cut it down and if you had a problem with cutting down a tree people would look at you like you were
crazy um or you were called a tree hugger we all remember that well those of us are old enough
so it turns out as the years have gone on they have and i put this in the um comment section
if anyone is interested in looking it's just a list uh it doesn't sign any sources but it is accurate
that that biologists have discovered that like trees they have a different way of thinking but
they do think and i don't think a lot of people know that they've discovered that they feel that
they communicate that they communicate through their i'm going to call it mycelial again but it's not
it's it did not mushrooms but it's like the tree version of the mushroom roots right like i'll know it
next time cilia through the cilia they communicate with each other through their cilia when one tree
gets cut down like grandma the tree the other trees feed it right like so if there's a large tree
that tree will dispense sugar to the other trees and then if that tree gets cut down
the other trees will begin sending sugar to the stump of that tree there's something called crown shyness
where trees will grow right but their foliage won't touch they will naturally their foliage will grow
around each other so that it they maximize the amount of space covered with foliage but minimize any
any death or harm they can do to each other by touching each other the more they are finding out
about trees the more that they realize that we have like this life form all around us
that can live 50 years 60 years 300 years 3000 years in some cases that has a rudimentary kind
of intelligence and has a rudimentary kind of feelings and i know that's a crazy thing for a lot
of people to think about particularly because you know like everything else in this world our relationship
to trees if you think about it if you start to accept they have some kind of intelligence or that
reframes things all of a sudden it becomes problematic right for some but not all of us
um but that's that's human life i don't think trees have any dna
so the role that the that that rick and morty gives the tree is like the demiurge role
right the the the demiurge is the ancient concept that um the reality overlay the simulation
is created or maintained intern there are archons who created it but internally it's ruled and
maintained by a demiurge a public worker god um so not like god in the sense that we think about it
now but as like um a higher intelligence that maintains life around us it was a book that i read
in the 90s and one of the books that changed my life i'm not going to say it's like profoundly written
the subject was profound it was it's the anthem it's um a gentleman was doing research for his uh
dissertation and he did it on um the uh the experiences people were having while they were using psychedelics
and distilling that into like a communication from the natural world to the individual
and what the the common communication was and what he discovered was that the around the world
wherever you look in these different cultures you will see that there are these motive motifs in art
that don't make much sense to us they often involve like snakes or snakes winding together
or a snake with a lion's head which is the traditional image of the demiurge dragons etc
and uh they they i mean no one really understands why we make that art um
and what he found was when you when you when people go through certain type of experiences
psychedelic experiences using the ayahuasca and other um sort of obscure to us uh psychedelics but very
powerful psychedelics um they have those visions and that's probably where this information is coming
from and not only do they have these visions of these snakes and lions and entwined snakes but they
often um will receive some sort of information and i think his original um his original thesis i think
dealt with um uh oh come on come on come on i'm slipping now uh dealt with uh the fact that
i think of the name so when you look at food or um when you like the way that native people
um the way that they identified herbs and foods and what they could do like how they could heal the
body what medicinal value they had or what they were good for was that there's a resemblance
it's called the doctrine of signatures there we go that's what i was looking for
so if you look it up it's called the doctrine of signatures and it's the weird thing that like
uh if you cut a carrot it looks like an eye and it's good for your eyes uh kidney beans are good for
the kidneys ostensibly right or good for the heart i think and um snake bite root looks like a snake
so like a natural medicine um for snake bite has a flower that looks like a snake and so that's how
people would find it so the idea was how did um indigenous peoples originally come up with the idea
that if you want to know what a food is good for you look and try to find what it represents resembles
in the human body and his thesis was or what the conclusion he came to was that they were accessing
this information through these hallucinogenics that they were communicating with nature and or gaia or
whatnot and when he did his research he discovered that that was the experience that people were having
that they were having these experiences and they were having a communication with like the spirit
of nature that was telling them things about their life um their relationships um it's almost become a
joke because you know um like business leaders and stuff will go down to mesoamerica and they'll trip
out on ayahuasca and then they'll like quit their job and they'll become like traveling circus carnies
they'll leave their wife and they'll leave their husband like they have this um experience that they
say it's like spiritual but oftentimes it like totally disrupts their life well it's because they're
being told this stuff by this entity all right so what's the what's the point the point is the entity
is symbolized by these entwined snakes and what he realized and the book is called the cosmic gene
was that the the visuals of the entwined snakes or the snake with the lion's head represented dna
and at the communication that people have when they're on these
hallucinogens they're communicating with dna itself
and at that point in time it was the concept of bio photons was unheard of
for a lot of people it still is but it is now an established uh scientific fact that um your dna
all dna gives off light and it gives off a certain type of light called a bio photon
it produces that light and it releases it and his theory that i think is gaining uh slowly gaining
acceptance is that dna communicates with itself that life as we see it is sort of the the mask
right now we experience that mask like on an individual level like we we have an identity
we like go through our life and we um you know we do human things we get jobs we get married we get
by houses but underneath it all there's a network that connects us all and that is this bio photonic
network connecting dna and if that's true and if there are communications that are occurring between all
life like on um on an a photonic level then dna is the cosmic serpent it's the demiurge
and uh if we ever talk about this again another episode i'm assuming we will like there are there is
reliable reliably consistent information related to the nhi phenomenon that people receive during these trips
as well as well as human history like reliably consistent stories are told to people um or people
come back with reliably consistent stories about that so it's so consistent and and uh ubiquitous that
i've always seen it as being like a source a primary source of information um while i understand that
it could be deceptive information like i try to balance that with other sources and say like what do these
sources have in common um and so i've always considered dna to be the demon the demiurge so
in that in that way like the trees themselves the world trees themselves whatever they were
the role that they played metaphorically right or actually connecting all life through this root
system is is in in our reality overlay that that internal structure that can that that system of
connection that is is being maintained through the the cosmic serpent through dna which is if you think
about it very similar to the idea of a psyllium network of roots connecting everything but with
the incorporation of the bio photons which i know makes it a little bit you know of a digression
so yeah i mean i i thought that that that uh analogy or the the story of the rick and morty episode
was perfect and fits perfectly with everything we talk about and i really appreciate that you brought it up
oh um i'm sorry to cut you off uh i wanted to say this for the record because morgan is here now
i should have said this at the very beginning without talking about his personal astrology i can say
that um earlier this year that he was considering going on a trip to mexico and at that time uh he
asked my opinion i said my opinion is you should not go the reason that's relevant it's not relevant to
anything except the fact that you're my brother and you're here talking about your trip to mexico this
summer and so i just wanted to say that at that time there was fighting going on in in mexico that
seemed like it was going to spread uh terrorism and insurgent type stuff and morgan's particular
astrological chart indicated that if he should go there um there could be a dangerous situation
or the situation with that where there was a possibility of contracting some sort of disease
or something so i i said look you know uh people go places that are dangerous all the time but if you
ask me whether i would say you should go or not i said i wouldn't because you have to caution your
principle when you're consulting with people right so obviously mexico did not just did not um
implode into like mad max style fighting or whatever so um it did turn out that the the fate uh met him
where he was as opposed to where he might have been so that's something that you find in like
in stories and in um in legends um in the bible right you find the the story of somebody who tries to
avoid their fate by going someplace other than where they would have been but they find the fate there
um and and so if you're ever i mean if you're ever talking to someone who's consulting as an
astrologer or something you know keep in mind like it's very likely that whatever is destined to happen
to you is destined to happen to you you know or fated to happen to you is fated to happen to you
wherever you end up being right um but if you're talking to someone and you ask them like should i go to
someplace that you know you perceive as dangerous they have to say no of course i wouldn't tell you not
to go so but i didn't want you know to be sitting here laughing and joking about matt's trip to the
yucatan and have you know morgan sitting there fucking steam
without explaining that it was you know months later and things had changed etc
so uh i'm gonna um pass it to you for a minute matt and uh i'm trying to think what else we were
talking about uh yeah um i think that was pretty much it for the topics related to the trip and the rick
and morty episode we had discussed potentially doing some astrology topics maybe um i mean we recently had
talked about the eclipses uh and maybe there's some room for talking about like the mundane
part of that i don't know if that's the right way to say it but just like what would what would apply
to most people rather than necessarily what would apply to me but yeah we could talk about that sure
um i think we also talked about um like we're sort of getting our stride right so matt and i've never
launched into a project like this before and i think that we always knew that we would but he's um he's
much younger than i am uh my father is was good at getting married and um so uh matt matt is younger
than i am and so we've never been in a place in life where we can like synchronize to to launch a project
like this uh before and and so we don't have any experience like running a project like this
with each other where we might have experience separately right and so we're kind of like sort of
finding our way with the plan to stick it out and have things continue to get better not that they're
not good now but like have things you know have the show find its own voice as time goes on
right and um you know matt had mentioned to me that he had that he had always been security minded
um and it's hard sometimes because you know even though he's my brother i like you don't you don't
always think a lot about the ways that you're different from other people right like you you're trying to
find commonality especially when there's like a a large difference like you're older or you grew up in
different places etc you focus on the things you have in common i am not materialistic at all and
that's not a indictment or anything it's just not part of my nature i uh when i was younger um i learned
how much um like people would make um how much an american income at that time was around the world
an average american income and at that time if you had an average american income um you you were in
the top five percent of wealth in the world and i said you know what that's good enough for me because
i don't think for me um i think the accumulation of wealth is um a detriment to whatever i'm meant to
do now what's ironic about that is that i wound up being catastrophically injured after a life of not
acquiring wealth so i'm actually a cautionary tale right like i i would never tell someone to focus
on acquiring wealth but i would also point out like you know do better than i did because if you're
catastrophically injured and you haven't saved money um that creates an entire like set of problems
that wouldn't be there right so it's good that people think about like security and it's good that
people think about like saving up for a rainy day or when they get older but it's it's just going to
take a little bit of time to get used to because we haven't had conversations like this so you know
my i never think about things in these subjects like hey how could we monetize that or how could that
you know how would people make money doing that and most people do and so that's like a blind spot in
my analysis and that's something that you know matt has pointed out like a couple of times and i think
it's good to have him point that out because um you know i i am not good at thinking about that and
saying hey this this could be used in such and such a way to make money or um because it's just not part
of my my thing right like it's jarringly not part of my thing so um when it comes up i'm like what
why would you why would you bring that up into this conversation but it's good to have that perspective
um it's especially good with i'm not a remote viewer but as you know my friend is and
i know some remote viewers and it's difficult because in order to do what they what they're passionate
about and also in order to get the data that they need to bring to people right for our like
our our spiritual development our awakening but also you know like for our security in the future
like another form of security in the future is having this information and they can't do that
if they have to struggle to survive right so they have to be able to make some money um
if it's if it's if there isn't the demand for everyone who does rv to be able to do a profession
like morgan does in order to do it they still need to be able to make something right so they need
to be able to charge and they need to be able to work for people um you know on a on a case-by-case
basis but another way of doing that another way of um of uh funding right that the work that they do
uh is by providing people with financial um information so i've been i've been critical of
that of other rv groups because they get into the crypto a lot and i you know i'm sure there are
people there's like 10 people here and or eight people here and um i'm sure some of them are in
crypto because on x everyone is in crypto right i don't mean to disrespect anyone um largely it's
gambling right so um you know i never think about like hey how can how could we steer more remote
viewers into giving crypto advice and i've been critical of the groups that do give a crypto advice
or that sell trotchkes i shouldn't be right it's none of my business really but it it does spark a
little indignation in me um having financial information um to offer people as a service
is a way that remote viewers and other prognosticators can fund what they're doing so i think that it's
important that that is developed as well and i'm glad that matt has brought that up because
it's a blind side now i'm thinking in those terms um and so we'll talk more about that in future
episodes so um okay so astrology
i've mentioned this i think in our first podcast episode and i may have gone on a little bit too much
about it um we're going through a period right now uh so there's what we all know there's uh western
astrology and there's vedic astrology and i'm not particularly uh pro vedic astrology and i'll tell
you the reason because uh a lot of what is vedic astrology was brought to india by the greeks when
alexander the great conquered northern india and so for years that was debated it's no longer a
debatable historical fact it can be debatable amongst practitioners who don't want to deal with
the historical facts what they have now found the actual copies of the ancient texts that were brought
there with them right so the thing about vedic astrology is it's a union of two of indigenous
um or not really hindu like um dravidian but the union of like dravidian and a little bit of hindu
astrology and then it's um it's western astrology and it's merged together and all seen through a specific
cultural mindset and i don't think in many cases and this is my experience that it's it's um
that it's comparable to a modern western astrologer i don't however i've had a blind spot a blind spot to
what they do do well and they really well objectively and that is there i believe it's probably somewhat
like um indo-arian and somewhat dravidian i'm not positive exactly but that that um indian stream
in vedic astrology is all about the study of in my opinion the unconscious influence in human affairs
so western astrology we deal with fate uh i mean if you're a good astrologer you do i know a lot of
other astrologers deny it but it's true so you deal with fated events but the focus is primarily on
external factors you look at like changes in in an individual right and you look at um transits
right changes in an individual would be progressions or solar arc or okay um
changes uh in in someone's life circumstances that are faded and external to themselves or transits
but they're all like an external influence it's a metaphorical influence but it's all
like the world around like the visible world around you with a few exceptions to like some of the
planets like some neptunian stuff and but even then like pluto is it represents the the plutocracy right
it's like the hidden money um behind a lot of the problems in the world um but that money is is it's not
visible to us but it is visible on earth right like a secret society um you may not know who's in the
secret society you may not know where they're getting together or what like weird robes they wear
right and if they have like a little uh pepper medallion that they wave in the air when they
shout esoteric stuff or gobbledygook or whatever they do but we know that they're there somewhere
because it's still external because it's still like a group of people meeting in a room doing
something even if it's hidden from us now the the the vedic principle of the nakashatras the lunar
mansions we have lunar mansions in western astrology it's not very well developed and there are some
people who use a more developed system than others but the lunar mansion systems that i've seen in
western astrology are not comparable with the vedic system and um not necessarily very useful in my
opinion so i didn't pay much attention to the hindu nakashatras that having been said i now recognize
the error of my ways i would not consult a vedic astrology to talk about my transits
um or i would do so um secondarily to consulting a western astrologer but what they're talking about
when they talk about nakashatras when they talk about the nodes of the moon being these invisible
planets i'm not saying they are but they believe they are um k2 and rahu when they talk about that
they're actually talking about the influence in organizing human affairs that comes from the
collective unconscious like really invisible influence right not hiding from us not somebody in the
basement making the call no person making the call no person being activated by a planet or influenced by
a planet or the or the cycle that we measure by using the planet but actual internal invisible
influence that is welling up through the collective unconscious into our minds in a in the waking moment
and most especially in our dreams and we experience it as art we experience it as science fiction
you know comic books if you're into comic books right or just fictional stories or legends and myths or
um synchronicities like all of that falls into the category of intrusions from the collective
unconscious into our waking world or our sleeping world if we're sleeping when it happens right
and what we don't recognize or we don't do well of recognizing as a culture is that those intrusions
are not random those intrusions have a purpose and that purpose is the internal organization of our world
so we have an external organization and we all know this external organization it keeps getting bigger
right as a matter of fact the reason one could speculate that external organization that's imposed
on us keeps getting more complicated and onerous is because there's an attempt to cut off
the internal organization to just overwhelm it to make everything so restrictive that nothing unaccounted for
or unconscious can motivate us or cause an event to happen okay so one reason that might occur
is because people's roles in the world can be altered and this shows up in the original
astrological practices where they were focused on eclipses and the relationship between the eclipses of the sun and moon
and events in the lives of royalty and important people
astrology was compiled over a 500 year period in babylon
um during an experiment called ordinary watching
it also appeared in egypt i don't know
they were connected as civilizations at that time i don't know
um where that connection happened like i can't tell you the exact year i can tell you like
roughly you know 600 bc in babylon to like roughly 100 bc
i can't really tell you um uh how the egyptians connected to that like where but there was a connection
right so that information is the genesis of world astrology and it started with the um
measuring the events or the notable events mostly threats right like threats to the reign of the ruler
and trying to figure out magical ways to circumvent the threats to the reign of the ruler
by studying the the eclipses so when eclipses happen particularly solar eclipses
male figures leave environments if you work in a building with 500 people 300 people 100 people
you will have and you chart the phenomenon you will notice that uh twice a year or whenever there's an eclipse
a prominent man a man in the spot will disappear from the workplace he'll get fired or he'll leave
or he'll pass away unfortunately but mostly it's getting fired to be honest
um but oftentimes the people leave as well and depending on where um the eclipse falls in your natal chart and whether it
strongly aspects uh planetary you know a natal planet or point right will determine whether
um a male figure and generally male solar eclipse is just i don't know i i don't know why the universe is engendered but often it is
so uh and that's that is actually uh very relevant to a practicing astrologer because we've lived in a time
when the gendered terminology has kind of changed and the approach to gender has changed and so the
question is well what should an astrologer do to adapt to that and the answer is there's really nothing you
can do so i guess it's really not engendered so much as relating to sex right biological sexes
and so that cuts that can cause a problem um if you have any traditional astrology in your practice
and you happen to be working with someone who doesn't identify with um with the gender they were
assigned to birth um let's let's leave that there uh
so in the ancient world this was particularly notable because this is a time when the king might disappear
right there were um there are other times when there can be regime changes um like the great
conjunctions of saturn and jupiter um which happened every 20 years but specifically when there were
eclipses if they were particularly if they were visible in the heavens um they would be concerned
that something would happen to the ruler or the chief priest or you know the chief scribe or something
but you know someone in that ruling position because it is so um
it is so automatic that uh during those periods uh during eclipses there's a internal reorganization
an unexpected internal reorganization that takes place despite what anyone wants
they developed actually some very uh elaborate rituals which we'll definitely talk about in a future uh
episode the rituals that the ruling class has developed over time in order to create scapegoat rulers
for the purposes of having those rulers get eclipsed out during eclipses this is actually
like it's egyptian it's babylonian and it's in use today in the modern world
where um where surrogate rulers are installed for the purpose of getting eclipsed out
so that the ruler himself can maintain his rule
um
we right now are in a particularly notable period because we have this eclipse and it's eclipse in leo
which is the king it happened in august uh it's actually the fourth in our lifetime maybe more depending
on how old we are uh because there was uh an eclipse on august 11th in um 1999 at 19 degrees leo
leo and um one in uh 2018 and 19 degrees leo they repeat every uh 19 years there was uh an eclipse in
2007 this is apropos because anything that occurred in your life in august of 2007 or around that time
probably is repeating in some way or rhyming in some way now
and uh we had this in august 12th um of this year and those are at 20 degrees leo so separated by one
degree but close enough that it's it's very similar um the 99 and uh 2018 were north node eclipses they
were focused on the future um these uh 2007 and 2026 are south node eclipses that's things going into
the past um or in the case of an eclipse in leo uh a changing of the guard where the leadership the
royalty the visible face of um of society the king uh is removed and is not removed through external
forces but through fate through sync uh synchronistic events beyond anyone's control
this is not just happening on a global level this is happening um in all of our lives depending
on where this eclipse occurred in your chart and whether that um the eclipse was aligned closely with
um nato planets uh in aquarius uh in aquarius or uh is this uh yeah in aquarius or uh
mostly in aquarius but i think um
yeah uh
taurus or scorpio probably um if you have nato planets there uh then you should look or points
then you may that are close um the orb for eclipses is generally five degrees people disagree on the orb
um there are some people that use wider orbs than others the orb is the number of degrees that you
consider like um the distance in the chart from the planet that would still be the area where it
could be activated so that's that's all technical stuff um in this case we've had this really
prolonged period where the the wandering south node is hovering over um
the star uh regulus now people who if you're familiar with astrology you're familiar with regulus
one of the royal stars right if you're um familiar with ufology you're familiar with regulus because of
the ufological predictions of chris bledsoe meaning that something big was going to happen this year and
it would be signaled by an event related to regulus in october well originally he said in april that
it's so complicated we're going to do an episode on chris bledsoe at some point to set the record
straight because he really mangled everything up but
if you are familiar with chris bledsoe you know regulus the royal star so the south node uh katu has been
um sort of hanging out over and i'm again i'm not a vedic astrologer okay he's been hanging out over
regulus and that process or the process that we've all experienced um is one of sort of a transition from
leadership or a preparation for possible leadership in the future and um
this is what i understand and there's actually like a formula for looking at what areas in your
life this might be occurring it's a vedic formula and it's beyond our purview today
however it aligns with or it um it's adjacent to the eclipse that occurred in august right well so
regulus right now is at about in the western chart it's uh western zodiac like 29 and change degrees leo
and the eclipse was at 20 and change um degrees leo so the eclipse is influenced by the node that it's
it's close to at that time and usually in eclipse you have um a couple months of activity and then
perhaps if you're a government or a nation or people uh 90 days later or 100 days later something might
happen that might be a natural disaster or um a former leader might pass away
however these eclipses can be activated right by uh transiting planets particularly two planets
um uh the the the peak activation would be from the planet mars which is called the activator
all right basically it's a it's a planet that often triggers other transits when it crosses their
path you can think of it in those terms right when it crosses the the planet involved or that degree
uh jupiter can also activate eclipses and jupiter is the the planet that represents kingship
so um an eclipse in in leo is related to kingship in some way or the spotlight i've talked about this
in the past like it also includes uh children uh it includes uh uh banquet halls and uh bar rooms and
taverns and and plays and anything that involves um leisure because the king lives a leisurely life
and um it also includes influencers which is particularly notable because one thing i've
been harping on for years is you know we're living in a period where like not only our influence is
going to disappear but there's going to be like a a social reaction to where people who were formerly
involved in uh in quote influencing right uh suffer similar hostility uh to that suffered by the petty
nobility in the 1780s and in 1790s which buried depending where you were in the world but was was
significant anyhow uh jupiter is going to cross the eclipse point on august 3rd and not only that but it
it will continue forward it will go retrograde it will begin to from our vantage point back up
and it will cross that point two more times the last passage being on june 7 of uh 2027.
mars will cross this is very notable mars is going to cross the eclipse point on november 3rd the day
of the election in the united states and it too will go retrograde and then it will back up to like 21 degrees
so almost back up fully to the point of the eclipse not quite but enough to to have some activity
when jupiter crosses this point the eclipse right it's it's like the birth or the conception
of a ruler but who that ruler is is going to vary depending on what level of society we're looking
at so we're talking about like the conception of a ruler on a national level wherein we may see
candidates emerge who go on to win elections who go on to have prominent roles now we're not facing
at this time the replacement of the leader of the united states
it's always possible that something like that could happen but we don't want to focus on
things like that we don't want to focus on instability uh that is something that could
happen but we could also see an emerging figure politically i guess is this um this shiny
new politician from texas young man down there who's running for office
uh who's really captivating people i'm not predicting anything specific to him i don't know
his chart or anything but i can say that having a new sort of young politician emerge on the scene
who immediately you know mostly male because it's a solar eclipse that's you know um who sort of
rapidly great gain status nationally would would fit perfectly with what's happening here
mars so that's the beginning right so that's like um eight month period i think uh yeah close to
eight month period um where that's going to be um
sort of the genesis of that new leadership right so that's something that's been happening behind the
scenes bubbling up through the collective unconscious through the lunar mansions right
reorganize reorganizing us as a society through synchronicity without us being aware of it just
completely invisible to all of us uh the eclipse you know removes leadership it removes people from
leadership positions that can also happen whenever jupiter crosses that point it can happen whenever
mars crosses that point so the fact that mars is crossing that point on november 3rd would tend to
indicate that you're going to see a large swath of leadership removed from their position now before
anyone is like yeah yeah my team right we're not political here but if we were we would have to
caution that um do not jump the gun and assume uh which side politically will be removed right because
a a a a leadership can be removed but a party can remain so i'm not making any predictions but i'm just
saying like before you know anyone takes that and says okay this guy is predicting that one party will
emerge maybe um but you could also see something else uh particularly um and again not making a prediction
but mars is marshall right so you could see a an event related to something marshall occurring at that
time as well i'll just say that um
the the development though the process right so when uh i'm getting lost here so when jupiter right
crosses that um the eclipse point it's going to go on to trine saturn um it's we're in the process of
jupiter trining saturn we talked about the great conjunction and how it relates to leadership so
what's important about that is there are two more trines between um jupiter and saturn during this
period the last trine between jupiter and saturn is in july of this um of this part of the great
great conjuncture cycle so the reason i mentioned that is it's relatively close to this um the
final uh jupiter crossing the uh the eclipse point right so i would look at a large transition in
leadership occurring uh through acts of fate over this period i wouldn't again make any predictions
about what party it's going to be and i don't think that focusing on like american politics or global
is the best way to utilize this information because this information is also relevant to
um your life you'd have to look at your chart to see how it affects you right and what area of your
life this this change is going to take place but there are people right now or maybe you have people
recently who were in a leadership position the we're in the spotlight in areas of your life who are no longer
there right and that may be you but more than likely right there are far more people than there are
people in the spotlight so uh it's quite possible that you will have an opportunity for the spotlight
you're not going to really have um this is not like one of these things where you're in a competition
and if you work hard and out compete everyone you're going to win and get the no this is like fate is
going to play a hand right but it is playing a hand so it's not going to be for everyone but for some
people there's going to be this um transition in leadership around them and potentially themselves
transitioning into a leadership position that can look again can look a lot of different ways
and so the reason i connected to what we were talking about earlier is when matt and i were were chatting
online and we were talking about you know the sense of of that we would one day start a podcast well
the period where we've kind of had this idea this was a little bit before the eclipse but it's really
been around that period right that it's come together suddenly unexpectedly that we would do this
and i've always made it a point not to be invasive with esoteric topics um not not to really
evangelize matt with esoteric topics because he's my he's my you know younger brother much younger
brother and there was always sort of a stigma around that idea because it was just my my weird
preoccupations right to people in my family i mean you might be you can be the you can be a hero to the world
but uh to your family you're you know you can still be just the the weirdo with odd preoccupations so um
matt brought it up sort of out of nowhere and it was right around that period that we we started
pulling this idea of of building this podcast together it doesn't mean again right like we're
talking about like kings and people in the spotlight on a national global level we're also talking about
spotlight on a small level so something like getting together and starting a podcast i'm not saying it
will be small who knows we might be very successful but that is very um
uh it fits very well with this process that we're all going through right now
so i don't know how that would take place in everyone's life but like what we're doing regardless
of how modest it may turn out is sort of a faded activity and i know that there are other people
with us today who are going through a similar situation um a faded reordering and restructuring
of the life that's occurring right now and so if you can sense that about your life the value of what
i'm saying is that you can anticipate these events occurring at certain periods of time you can
anticipate events occurring on you know around october 3rd around november 3rd you can anticipate
the situation revolving or revolving resolving next year between uh june 7th and july 12th now
obviously i can't say anything more specific without looking at someone's chart but i can say that if
you're experiencing this that that is your time frame right that's how it's going to play out i can also
say that one of the things we've talked about for years here i mean it's been a year we've
talked about it for years we've talked about it in spaces for a little more than a year one of the
themes that we're going through and it's very difficult for people to internalize because it's
happening so goddamn slowly the end of the world takes forever uh as i say so it's happening so
slowly that we're like a frog boiling in a pot right like to use that cliche and it's difficult to
consciously keep track of the changes that are happening in the world relative to a person's
social and physical mobility but we are right now in a period maybe the and i know this is kind of
depressing to think about but maybe the last period in our lives in this physical incarnation
where we have this level of physical and social mobility when we were talking about it two years ago
or even a year ago right i know it sounds strange to say this but a year ago it was not as serious
a topic to think about like the effect of ai it was serious ai was real and we knew like okay ai is
going to start replacing jobs but they were saying in five years a year ago they were saying in five years
all these industries are going to lose jobs so when i would give when we talk about spaces be like okay
well that's what they're saying but i'm telling you this is going to happen like you're going to
experience this limitation sooner it's not just going to be because ai well now they're talking about
next year right they're talking about next year people experiencing limitations in their lives because of the
lives because of the progress of ai is such limitations as the lack of potential social mobility and career
mobility in the future right wherein there may not be a career path for you where you can do a better
job than a computer program and if that is the case and those computer programs are widely adopted
then there there may be a path for you to survive right but the traditional dream of elevating
oneself from the working class up into the middle class potentially becoming wealthy that dream that's
gone i know it's hard for people to hear but it's true and that's what we've been talking about right
and so i've been running these spaces for you are saying look i'm not like i am not somebody who can
stand up and say hey look at all the fascinating things that i've done the accomplishments that i've
achieved be like me that's not it right but what i'm saying is like what i can tell you
is that all of these dreams that you've had like there's going to be a limitation on them right there
will be a financial and physical limitation now there are things you will always be able to do
some things right but if you dream of traveling and air travel isn't available that's going to be
difficult if you dream about becoming a successful corporate ceo and ai eliminates that path for you
right then you're going to have to find another dream and that's something that people would never
say in our entire lives and as a matter of fact if you told someone that and you know you would be
there would be a social stigma to you saying that to someone because it was being negative it was
it was experiences being demeaning this isn't like just singling one person out to say that this
is all of us now and you know i i've been running these spaces last year i said look set the goals
and do it now right well so we have the ai developments but here's the thing we've also been
talking in spaces a lot about the the the war the escalating war and how it would continue to escalate
all right and oftentimes when the a new front has emerged um or or the u.s has to send military to
one area or the other right then the media will just sort of forget right so when's the last time
you heard about the the battles going on in africa most likely not for years right not since wagner
was deployed as as africa force right but there have been continuous uh uh changes in the power
structure in africa governments being overthrown western nations being kicked out of african
nations for years now no one hears about it right and it's the it's the russian forces that are doing
it okay so the middle east war people think oh it's not related i mean october 7th is vladimir
putin's birthday why do you think they why do you think they launched the attack on october 7th
uh the those groups groups like hamas whatever you think whatever your politics are whatever your
your religion is what set all that aside for a second okay there is a network that connects
states like iran as client states of the russians and chinese and those groups are clients of states
like iran and so they may be one step removed but they are not disconnected from that network
right so the iranians don't do anything unless the russians and chinese know and the houthis and hamas
right they don't do anything unless iran knows and you know by proxy you can say they're not doing
anything large unless russia and china know and people don't recognize that so this has always been
one war one conflict and it's escalating and one of the signs of that escalation is that ukraine is
suddenly in the center of the picture as opposed to iran now iran is mobilizing another million troops so
that's not going away right yemen is right the houthis are going to take yemen and they're going to
you know invade saudi arabia and they may take they may take control of saudi arabia the house of sod has
done some some things that people don't like they don't approve of right and everyone just sort of glossed over
the fact that the humanis the houthis began their conquest of yemen on september 11th but on the
same day the united states declined to help saudi arabia so it could be seeing patterns where patents
don't exist but occam's razor tells me that the this it's probably not a coincidence that you know
saudi arabia is now in a fight for its life that began on september 11th right and at that time the united
states and nato declined to assist it when it was counting on our assistance right to survive
so um like these things are happening and um depending on what objective the government
slash governments have the media is reporting things differently to different groups of people so
every time an oil pipeline blows up which is happening every day right like oil facilities
refineries are blowing up all the time it's happening particularly in russia right now this is going to
kick the europeans in the ass because the europeans rely on russia to heat their homes in the winter
and the europeans are sending weapons to the ukraine ukraine is attacking russian oil facilities and the
russians just tore up their gas contracts with with um with germany and the germans don't really know
what they're going to do in the past the russians have sort of backed down last minute and sold them the
the gas but they only did it because the united states could sort of make up the difference and
they didn't want to give us an advantage the united states can't really make up the difference
right now because we're in the middle of a global fuel crisis so it's quite possible that the russians
intend to to let europe freeze this winter all right that's right we're right we're coming months away
from seeing whether that's true or not um at the same time the you know the houthis have said that
that they are not going to shut down the bab uh bab el mondi strait and i apologize again i'm i'm i'm
very good speaking english never mind speaking you know using these foreign terms um to anyone but
saudi arabia but saudi arabia ships oil to china saudi arabia ships oil to europe so the united states
we are the world's largest oil producer but the problem is the refineries where where you refine fuel
are generally located next to where the customers live as opposed to where the producers live
right so venezuela pumps a lot of heavy sour crude which is refined in china it's not refined in
venezuela right and so when you have american leaders who say hey we're going to just we're
going to get a gift from venezuela we're going to get a bunch of venezuelan oil and that's how
we're going to stay afloat this winter we don't have the refinery capacity for that oil we don't have
the storage capacity for it either right because it's very acidic you can't store it in salt caverns
where you store the type of oil that we produce because of the way this system is globalized
you can't really make these substitutions but here's the thing our government is amazing
whatever your politics are our government is so incredibly competent and powerful you may not believe
that right until you really get into studying this stuff because everybody since i was a kid said
if iran united states went to war it would cripple the global economy there would be food shortages
there would be gas shortages like not mad max but bad everywhere right they all said that there was no
disagreement about that well this has been going on since april and i don't have to wait in line for gas
supermarkets are full of food i get my prescriptions just fine and that is in the face of every prediction
that people have that shows you the power that our government has to control prices when they need
to and to control supply when they need to and the amount of oil that we produce
however there is a breaking point and the thinking is that very soon we will run out of the oil that
we use to pressurize pipelines all right so the oil that you store in the ground isn't just for a rainy day
the weight of that oil also is the force that pushes the other oil through the pipelines
that that go across the continent and that's how heavy it is that will push oil from
you know from uh one side of the america of america to the other or from um one side of saudi arabia to
the other right and when you hit a certain point of um when you reduce your strategic store stockpile or
your your your stores of oil to a certain point the oil can't flow anymore there's no way to really make
that happen there's no machine that can pressurize those pipelines only the weight of the oil can
so as amazing and incompetent as our government is whether you like our government or not like
that's it's just i'm telling you as amazing and competent as our government is there is a line beyond
which the events of the oil shortage will come home and the thinking is that at least for most of the
world we have now entered that period says people are quote experts and people who represent oil
companies are saying this all the time now who knows if it's true um like we we found ways of
we found ways around it over the last few months right but at some point we won't be able to and so
right now the u.s i think the senate it should the law should come to the house of representatives but
i believe it's a united states senator who's saying we should ban the export of diesel gas
the russians of course have been the export of diesel gas the chinese have been the export of diesel gas
and um and we're now looking at export banning the export of diesel gas to keep it at home to lower
our prices but that same diesel right ships food the same diesel that ships food from the midwest
to your front door right ships food from a harbor in thailand to inner thailand or from
um one side of australia to another right like there's no place on earth where the price of diesel
isn't relevant and isn't tied to inflation so we are right at that point where for much of the world
if not the united states things like food shortages and transportation issues and um
medicine shortages could become real and should the situation continue right it's i mean it's almost
impossible that it won't become real for us at some point like beyond like these prices which are
horrible right and they're going to get worse so this war is not going anywhere iran is mobilizing
one million soldiers right and the russians are mobilizing at least a million like the war is going
to continue at the way it is now or it's going to heat up i believe it's going to heat up
so but regardless of whether you buy buy that or not
right the effects of the war of the war on the global economy and on global transportation are
going to limit physical movement social movement financial movement and mobility
and so this is really the time there are people right now who are talking about
you know stock up on medicine and food for your elderly parents because they're going to want to
call the elderly it's a little bit early for that in the united states for that thinking okay
but um it's definitely time to think about the fact that you know anything that you buy in the
store now is going to cost a lot later right and it may be unavailable you know and medicine is made
out of petroleum so it's always a good idea to have extra prescriptions it's always a good idea to have um
extra prescription medicine it's always a good idea to have a little you know you don't have to go
prepper you don't have to get crazy but it's a good idea to have a couple weeks of food right like
that's not like crazy prepper stuff the government wants us all to do that but you know most of us
don't pay attention right but they want us all to have two or three weeks of food just in case
something happens so this is the type of thing you want to think about now and again if you have
goals you have something you really want to do like this is the time to do it particularly if you're
younger right because and they're increasing the draft age next year to 42 42 or 44 i'm not sure
which one i think it's 42 but if you're 43 don't don't you know um take my word for it right like
do the research yourself because as of uh january the the draft age is going up and more than likely
there's going to be some sort of selective service because everyone else is mobilizing and we're going
to have to too right so and this is the time to do it this is the time to to to seize your dreams and
your goals to the to whatever extent you can do it now or set off down that path because
i always use this cliche like you don't have to outrun the beer right like i don't have to outrun
the beer i just have to outrun you now i don't really live by that motto but other people do and
that's how i often say like look this is how human beings act right like this is how human beings
secure themselves against threats okay that's they don't really worry about like is there going to be
a pole shift is it going to be like a solar flare like they don't worry about that stuff
because their protection is right the way they protect themselves against those threats is to seek
financial security right they worry about making money and owning things so that you know if something
really bad happens they're in the inside of the circle right and it limits the the negative
ramifications for them so that that's like the basic survival um philosophy we're not there you know
we're not at mad max right now but we are at the at the point where you know everyone agrees that next
year events are going to occur that start to limit our mobility this is relevant to the astrological
discussion because we're talking about like a a major civilizational shift right we talked about it
beginning in february um with the conjunction of of saturn and neptune and how that would take years to
unwind so now we're talking about the changes in leadership and roles in society that are happening
like faded that are happening right now right and so part of that that way that fate is active in the
world is through things like economics right things like economics that seem to be out of anyone's
control right so like you know fate not might not necessarily govern stock market crashes but it does
govern when the stock market crashes right i think it governs everything but from our point of view from
the from an operational standpoint right like that the issue is like we all know the markets you know
we all know the market's gonna have trouble right because of those things we see in the world but
we don't know when right that's the fate that we're talking about that that timing so um
this eclipse season this eclipse cycle is a good way of looking at um looking at it uh from the lens of
opportunity um is a good way to think about it let me rephrase what i'm going to say so like this is a
period of of potential personal advance and also uh the gaining of uh of leadership and the spotlight
things that might be um necessary right and if it's fated to happen it's going to happen but
you know why not prepare for it so um i look at people are freaking out now i would say after july
or after july 11th um that would be a time when i would be more worried i'm not saying that bad
things aren't going to happen between now and july 11th they most assuredly are like somewhere in the
world right like really terrible stuff is happening and and maybe to us as well but um comparatively
speaking i would look at this period through july 11th as a period of preparation right and so that's how
astrology i think ties into those different uh topics that we've had earlier um and from my perspective
um and like when we started talking about like matt's trip to um to latin america like that was a
dream and you know if you listen to that part of the of the episode right like him talking about like
all the amazing things he did like that's amazing and particularly that he had that opportunity right
so i would like if you have the ability to do something like that and you know the the means
um i would schedule it before next july that's what i would say and i would count on there being
obstacles but i just think that the obstacles in my personal opinion the obstacles would be greater
at that time and following that time and we're going to have more information about that we're going to
have more astrology based information we're going to have more remote viewing based information
we're going to have information from experts who aren't um in the field of astrology and reviewing
that all tends to suggest um this this window is closing unfortunately it's something that we
really don't want to accept because we've always we were raised in a society that told us that would
never happen to us all right so all right matt i think that's i think i i um covered all the bases there
but if i'm missing something um you will know better than i do because as you can see like
you know i didn't write it down as usual i'm ad-libbing and because i didn't write it down i
did a better job than i usually do right but um but that's why there are some pauses and have
to rephrase things and stuff because i don't i don't write this stuff out i don't have a script of
any kind but just me you know ad-libbing what do you got matt uh yeah i don't know if i have uh anything
anything else to add i mean that was very uh comprehensive uh so thank you um and i guess
yeah it'd be cool to um i don't know like to to to see how it might to theorize how it might um
affect people like just kind of like make up a chart honestly and then just like kind of like pull
up something random and then just kind of show how that might um i don't know influence like more
like less like more on the personal level i guess um but yeah i think like definitely we should have
like a separate and uh like probably a series of separate talks on on the war i think you could
probably talk a lot about that um there's so much happening all the time but in any case uh regarding
the eclipses yeah i don't really have um i don't really have anything to add i'm i'm very
new to the whole astrology thing like i know like a little bit but but certainly not not at that depth
so it was all very interesting and and thanks for thanks for sharing it was awesome we're going to
have um some comprehensive remote viewing related information on these subjects available next week
we don't have it this week um i'm not going to say anything more about it now but i'm just going
to say that next week if you if you have more interest in this subject and beyond my musings about the
the way the collective unconscious is working to reorder the world to sort of lead us to certain
ends um and how we can see that through using uh astrology um and you have an interest on you know
the other part of it like sort of the opportunity and and how to maximize the opportunity and uh we'll
we'll have that you know and you you're interested in the remote viewing perspective we'll have that
available next week but that's all i can say about that at this time um you know it should or the week
after depending on what we decide because i'm not look i'm not a dictator here right like matt and i do
this together and so it really depends on what we decide together about what the topic will be um
but sometime soon you know probably next week we'll we will go over that information and we'll continue
to circle back to it we'll also talk about you know near or closer to or on the 3rd of october
i'm not sure what day the 3rd of october is but maybe wednesday i don't know right we'll talk about
that um and we definitely will have a um november 4th right so november 3rd is going to be um when mars
crosses the eclipse point the election that's a tuesday so um we will have a podcast god willing the
next day and we'll cover you know i mean we don't get political here um but you know we can relate facts
and news without being political and you know analyze how it relates to the the theme of mars
crossing that that eclipse point and and how that might relate to the events of the next like seven
months after that so we're running a little bit later we're going to try to do like an hour and 15
minutes but it's amazing like i didn't know how much like how how much i go on about things
right and like i'm not the only one when people talk like they want to talk comprehensively right
so at first i thought these podcasts would be like 20 questions well we can do 20 questions in 90 minutes
huh it's a struggle to do five or five points and that's again that's not just me it's specific
it's especially me but it's not just me um it seems to be like my my perception of like how efficient
people could be and having a natural conversation was like way way off um
so this has been a little bit longer than what we're shooting for ideally we're going to shoot
for ideally we would have been done at 8 40 and we're we're gonna move in that direction but as
of now we don't have any listeners for the podcast which you know it's just i haven't promoted it right
and i haven't had a venue to promote it um so i'm not really worried about it but as time goes on
they're going to get smaller and i've considered doing like a podcast space plus a discussion space
so um x won't let me edit i'm sure there's plenty of software that can do it i don't have that um
expertise uh x won't let me edit the space so i can't do 90 minutes and then record another hour
or two where everyone like we talk in a freeform style where people ask questions and stuff so maybe
we're going to do two um and then matt won't you know he has things he's got to do so he'll be able
to go on his way and i'll be able to like hang out and answer questions if anyone has them uh but that's
not right now and that's sort of a process like i was saying uh our goal we stated last week is to
be present and to podcast from the contact in the desert event this year in california i think that
i'm not a huge like convention person i'm not not a huge vacation person although it's
it's means more than interest um but the fact that this year's contact in the desert is aligning
perfectly with the final pass of jupiter over the eclipse point um tells me that it might
be particularly relevant and it is a good networking not just for people who are interested in ufos but
for people who are interested in the paranormal ufos remote viewing like any of the topics that we cover
uh so that's the goal um god willing um the economy willing like if there's enough oil
to make you know jet fuel and fly us there etc uh so yeah that's just a little um
just sort of breaking down where we're going and um and i'm getting tired and i'm gonna close it out
now and it'll be more succinct next week uh thank you all for coming um and usually we like to go
through everyone but since we're just going to be recording for people who can't see you
um then it doesn't make any sense to do that but i'm looking at you all right now and i'm thinking
each person looking at i'm really grateful that you uh joined us for this recording all right there's
going to be a and matt unless you have anything else i'm going to close it up there'll be like a 15
second um pause before it disconnects